what's going on reject nation greg alba
errol here follow my friend on instagram
people we're going to watch
the season pro the premiere
of the finale we're going to watch the
finale of season 2
of umbrella academy today guys either
way subscribe and click the notification
bell
why not and just as a friendly reminder
we're only allowed to show 10 minutes
worth of the show
if we're lucky here up on youtube full
length reaction watch long's over at our
patreon page and this is the last time
i'll be saying
it this month we appreciate if you guys
showed your support to the real rejects
over at our patreon over there we cover
many shows that have the option for
watch along and reaction highlights
included at the same tier
those shows are supernatural doctor who
joe joe's bizarre adventures the
promised neverland attack on titan death
note
my hero academia code geass hunter
hunter one punch man full metal
alchemist brotherhood demon slayer and
violet evergarden and there are many
shows we only do watch alongs for them
and we also have a weekly q a podcast
really appreciate
everyone who's been going over to our
patreon page and showing their support
for this month alone means a hell of a
lot hopefully you're enjoying the
concert over there and because this is
the finale i'm gonna divide this into
two parts part one
here and then at the end of the video
you can click the card or the end screen
or link in the description box or pin
comment
for part two of the reaction which will
have the review
for the sew it as well let's do this
the last of us two 2006.
oh is this when ben died maybe
pogo's equation will back change
unless evil itself is wiped from
existence
none of you are sex people damn despite
years of training and weeks of
preparation you allow number six to die
on this mission
wow what a dick jesus
hold on to this we resume tomorrow at 6
a.m
geez good old dad oh
did ben just like show up right away no
i don't mean to say that has you been
talking to ben this long
ben grew up as a ghost
oh wow interesting she's been swearing
the same thing
hmm
wait so ben grew up as a ghost i guess
i didn't know ghosts can do that was
that that kid who's playing klaus's real
voice
umbrella hey there it is
oh gee she's still getting blamed
oh they're wanted
cuban
well they're all wanted
oh god
there's a picture of him
i am offended
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
no she remembers
it's times like this where i hungry we
have
help too subtitles thank you for not
leaving them out of the dark or in the
dark
yes
honey i love you girl yes
that makes me so happy [ __ ] diego
yeah it goes right what i need to make
stand here right now wow y'all i hate
y'all
you're really hot after everything you
went through are you serious this is
what
happened the first time what why would
you guys not
leaving her alone hasn't started in the
first place
wow this doesn't make [ __ ] sense what
are they staying for they have to leave
anyway
i love you [ __ ] klaus did he
say anything about me he did
whispered
it wasn't you inaudibly made him stay ah
all these years and i thought it was my
fault that he didn't take his ticket to
heaven
probably added to your guilt
[Laughter]
is the unknown alone
i love you guys what
what
just about luther yeah where's luther
he's gonna be right on top
oh no
luther damn you looper
yeah you're the beefiest man on earth no
one's calling you
god damn that's gonna be an annoying car
run
since i'll take something more discreet
isn't there a swede left
there is obvious have you seen these
episodes
the screen wasn't in the last one yeah
oh
there's swede and there's lila coming
after them
whoa whoa snow
i got a storm tower
[Laughter]
close enough oh my god the flash
jesus oh no harlan go in there
who just appeared
[Music]
oh
this was like the most comic bookie
ending yeah so
we'll see how it plays out right right
i've decided to eliminate the criminals
responsible for the assassination
you [ __ ] told you don't trust her
i thought five tells them everything
isn't that what you told lyla
what are you talking about
uh-oh she's trying to keep him shut
okay whoa
what the hell is there a frog back there
holy [ __ ] she has her x-men costume on
wow whoa there's so many different types
oh those are masks
holy [ __ ] damn that's an army right
there
oh it's gonna be cruel
this is so unexpected holy [ __ ]
oh if harlan divine just worked together
they could wipe them all out
i mean it's just the two women yeah
that's all they really need
wow these guys are terrible shots
hundreds of them assassins huh
no get in there vanya
[Laughter]
damn it it always doesn't work the most
game convenient times
i shouldn't have ran cover what are you
going to cover with
whoa somebody explain to me what the
[ __ ] is going on
how the [ __ ] is happening what do you
think you're doing diego
what
[ __ ] how in the [ __ ]
is that how he was able to manipulate
the knives oh is he does he have like a
magneto kind of effect
i guess or something what the hell
hi vaughn what's the matter yeah
come on let's go bass pushing the white
violin outfit
[ __ ] wow
no assist shadows
wow she can control our powers now what
they really gotta worry about is that
swede
that damn singular sweet
oh i'll just start something it's not
over
it's never over oh no
at the force field y'all yeah who was
that that was lyla in the handler it was
yeah does lila have powers
[Music]
link in description box pin comment and
screening card for a reaction of r2
you